morning to everybody and thanks again to
the sheriff always nice to have him
on our wednesday morning we've got
clouds to start off our day
and that's the way we finished our
tuesday and temperatures were pretty
chilly yesterday only in the mid
50s because of those heavier clouds as
we look outside off to the east
you can see that we still have a lot of
those out there they should be thinning
though as we get through the day
and we're starting a warming trend on
our wednesday
now this morning it's very cool out
there lots of mid 30s but remember
yesterday
valley wide we were down into the mid to
low 30s a lot of neighborhoods down
around freezing
we're a little bit milder than that just
barely because of the cloud cover
overnight still cold enough
for warm jackets and coats don't get me
wrong another system that's been moving
into the pacific northwest is starting
to shift now over into the rockies
rain and snow will stay well to the
north of us
but you can see the clouds 40s and some
30s up in the northwest this system
seems to be a little bit warmer than the
last one
that hit the pacific northwest those
clouds pouring
into nevada and over into the great
basin just kind of skimming the desert
and again they'll be thinning out as we
get through the day we should be seeing
more sunshine for our wednesday
afternoon
so we'll look for highs just getting
into the low 60s for a lot of
neighborhoods we'll see if we can make
it to 63 today the normal high of 58.
we'll pass that and every day through
the seven day forecast look at this
warming trend
even reaching for low 70s which is
pretty unusual
for mid-january mornings will also of
course get milder back into the mid 40s
70s into saturday but breezy winds
especially for the colorado river into
the weekend
and again early next week even for the
valley that will bring the numbers back
down to low 60s
after mlk monday let's get